hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at
Freddy's help-wanted okay so what I'm
going to do now is vent repair now
there's only two levels that I can see
and I'm pretty sure I can count to two
one and the other number that I don't
know so this one says mangle I'm not
sure what it means to do vent repair
grab her Annalise and pull trigger but
it probably has something to do with the
similarity to keep thinking there's
something over here also this mud and or
fecal matter is not very reassuring but
it says vent repair mangle so I don't
know but we're gonna find out ooh that's
too close to my face oh that's uh oh oh
wait a minute hang on a second Oh Oh
surely they must be joking Oh
surely surely they must be telling the
jokes here surely they must be saying
the jokes that looks like Squidward okay
alright I'm an idiot but here we go
welcome to vent repair I don't like it
fazbear entertainment prides itself on
having the most comfortable facilities
each facility is set to a perfect 72
degrees all the time the four active
indicator lights mean we have a well
functioning ventilation system
Oh your headlamp should protect you from
any critters who may have stumbled into
the ducts Oh as a certified vent
technician you should need new
instruction Oliver in case of an
emergency it is important to remember
that as the vent technician you should
never under any circumstances
wow wow wow oh they must be joking
oh they must Oh joking they must be oh
oh they must bad oh oh they must be
joking well they must well they must
they are telling all of the jokes where
what
bye-bye-bye what [ __ ] holy crap okay
all right uh you you you you you hey hey
wait
ah I hear you Squidward you peeing on me
okay hey oh oh oh they must well they
must be joking Oh [ __ ] god oh [ __ ] me
okay ah blue green blue god damn it ah
poop where he'll [ __ ] me
red yeah red orange blue green Oh
a perfect 72 degrees
good job see you next time
[Music]
I'm sorry for what was probably the most
fast ik gameplay footage you've ever
seen in your life well I am not sorry
for its the amount of poop in my pants
I'm not sorry for that in the least
Oh aren't you just the sweetest thing
you wouldn't mind if I ripped your eye
out would you no please you've been
ripped out
obviously it has finally a good old
finishing punch to the back of the nog
no anything like blink and you're dead
okay so let's go back to the most
horrifying thing I've ever do am I
reading that right is the VR messing
with my eyeballs or does a say entered
on it
and if it says energy was I mean for me
sister locations favorable Oh surely you
must be joshing you must be doing the
joke-telling I've heard so much about
you must be be reciting those hilarious
jokes the likes of which have only been
told in rumors and legends surely circus
babies entertainment and rental right it
has been zero days since last incident
oh oh
emergency ventilation repairs may be
necessary to reach the boiler room on
sub-basement G
for the claustrophobic become wary
service elevator but the comfort of the
main elevator is well above your
paygrade
now let's get to work I thought that was
where I was gotta be doing the things
and the stuff oh oh oh oh oh oh oh okay
all right well borrow motion trigger
breaker what does that mean okay what am
I here what am I here
I hear something okay you're all wrong
they're all wrong they're all wrong
[Music]
wait I don't get it
what am I missing what am I missing
okay here we go we got something oh wait
is it the corresponding light that goes
okay so that light goes to that one this
light goes to this one I did it it was
just the wires I wasn't paying attention
on paying attention
obviously okay all right Wow Wow Bowie
wait what I give
okay okay you're there oh [ __ ] oh okay
all right so it's gonna be like that huh
okay
that's fascinating that that is the way
that that is okay so what I didn't
realize is that I just needed to follow
the pattern well done with the wires
I didn't realize just guessing the
pattern until it was right I didn't know
that that was the thing that it was
[Music]
well done okay all right
I got this so I just can't make my son
I'm probably on a time limit but I just
need to not make mistakes I think that's
what really gets him going
he's really sassy like that okay you're
much closer than I would have liked Hey
okay you're okay
okay no no no no no no you you I should
have been done that should have been it
that was it right Oh surely this must be
what Oh yet another of your hilarious
goofs gasps and guffaws oh that doesn't
look friendly I doesn't look good at all
oh boy well good to know there's all
these hilarious gears and gizmos all the
way down here
[Music]
okay I'll take that thank you
motion trigger secondary service
elevator ventilation show that's that is
there like a gear am I supposed to oh oh
yeah yeah oh hi oh hi um what do I do
about you what do I do about you um wait
okay I'll take this one there okay all
right that's good right hey can I are
you gonna be a problem
oh hi hello how are you what do I do
about you ooh okay oh [ __ ] oh oh god oh
god
oh [ __ ] me oh oh oh oh [ __ ] me oh hey
look wait a minute wait wait you there
you don't you there you oh [ __ ] I don't
have anything that you need here I don't
know what I need
is there another gear or something
somewhere what do i do what do i do I
don't know what I do I don't know what I
do I don't know what I do how are you
there there's no thing there you're
still there
I don't did it I'm not I'm running low
on gears I don't have enough you're not
doing anything so I'm not 100% sure what
I do about that
Oh didn't have enough gears never left
gears and gizmos gears gasps goofs and
so this next way it's just gotta be
something about like skiers I just have
to get gears right
that's it I think so it's all here oh
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] was that
wait what did you guys see that there's
something there okay if I die again
which is almost guaranteed
apparently there's uh I think it was
like that that bonding toilet fun time
Freddie has sometimes is that like a
collectible that I could get I have no
idea okay
oh wait oh wait oh you motions me that
so that's what any service elevator
ventilation oh I need this to keep going
so I can get this this is gonna pump out
yeah yeah this this new oh wait why is
this not going this should be going
right do I need a [ __ ]
but that's not going there so I see what
I need over there
so this blocks that off but this doesn't
cause that to go there's another one oh
I see okay I get it I get it I get it
hi okay I get it hang on a second hang
on a second okay um get that out there
grab this put that there
this here no no there no no [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] not the coin
okay
oh [ __ ] no this here grab that good
night
and there and there done ha ha ha
there's more oh of course there's more
okay be on the lookout everybody be
kinda on the lookout for anything that
looks good that was the coin that I
dropped but I already got that one so oh
[ __ ] okay
all right everybody stop panicking
because this is on this manageable
oh boy why do I gotta go so far now why
is this place so big and this is a
rental shop isn't it oh that doesn't
look good
oh that does not look good okay um okay
motion trigger boiler room yeah no joke
okay no joke okay one and so it's just
this it's very simple done easy I guess
done okay not a problem
it's dark but not a problem oh god oh my
god oh my god oh oh my god
okay um okay to there then there but oh
my god oh I did it I guess oh it's dark
oh it's dark okay hands so I can see
button I trust button I shouldn't trust
button oh [ __ ] I don't trust button what
do I do
oh oh
what hey well done a perfect 72 degrees
see you next time what the [ __ ] what
what what did i do what did I just burn
a nerd did I burn did I burn a nerd
I'll trade certified to be delicious not
though not always need to know okay I
[Music]
think I burned a nerd I think I've
burned under a burn and herb I burned
I burned I'm not gonna do it right now I
just want to see what what uh what
nightmare then repair so you get both of
him never else to get one oh wait no no
you don't know you don't know you don't
know you don't oh my god oh my god okay
all right well I'm gonna [ __ ] that [ __ ]
they must be joking they must be doing
the joke's on me and I'm not one to
jokes I'm all choked out for now so next
up is the final of the normal modes
night terrors and then well night
terrors we move on that thing okay so
anyway but that's thankfully that's all
the time I have for this one thank you
everybody so much for watching I hope
you're enjoying this I'm having ton of
fun that so thank you everybody someone
for what Oh so thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know anything
down the comments below there's more
five nights at Freddy's all over my
channel I'll link in the description to
all their other cool stuff and just
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see
you in the next video by
[Music]